as a new football season kicks off liz
truss's campaign for the tory leadership
took her to national league club
solihull moores in the west midlands
where she spelled out her goal to tackle
soaring fuel bills
a message tax cuts not handouts
i know people are struggling with
fuel bills with food bills at this very
difficult time
and that is why i would have a temporary
moratorium on the green energy levy to
make sure everybody
is saving money on those fuel bills i
will always be thinking
of those who are struggling i know it's
very difficult times and i will do all i
can to help them as prime minister
but rishi sunak came out fighting he
took a hovercraft to the isle of wight
before returning to his home city of
southampton where he said liz truss's
proposals won't help pensioners
we need to get real about this situation
it's simply wrong to rule out further
direct support at this time as liz trust
has done and what's more her tax
proposals are not going to help very
significantly people like pensioners or
those on low incomes who are exactly the
kind of families that are going to need
help
the foreign secretary rejects mr sunac's
claims that her tax cuts will fuel
inflation
but top economists argue they will help
the rich more than the poor the
particular measures that this trust is
recommending
are not particularly well targeted in
terms of dealing with the people who are
most hit by the energy shock who's
suffering mostly
as she hammers home her tax cuts not
handouts message liz truss is also
accusing the treasury of abacus
economics orthodoxy and risk aversion
it's a convenient scapegoat because the
chancellor of the exchequer until he
quit last month was her tory leadership
opponent rishi sunak the former
chancellor admits that he's the underdog
in this contest but front-runner liz
truss continues to make her pitch to
tory members john craig sky news